hello this is Sal Khan of the Khan
Academy I'm here with David Coleman
who's president of the college board and
we're excited to together announced the
first launch of our collaboration
between the college board and the Khan
Academy to create the first ever
official s80 preparation for the new s80
and what I'm personally really excited
about is this is a very different s80
it's it's much simpler it's much more
focused on the things that students
actually learn in school the vocabulary
is vocabulary that you would actually
use in life as opposed to these kind of
you know crazy you know classic sshd
words when we redesigned the s80 you
know starting three years ago our whole
aim actually was to put students more at
ease we eliminated the penalty for wrong
answers as you know we want students to
be able to do their personal best on the
exam to show what they know and it's
also Ivan partnered with you with Khan
Academy to provide the best world-class
free test preparation in the world right
here working together closely with you
to make sure it focuses on what the exam
measures and helps kids advance so I
think what's so exciting about Khan is
done is whatever level of performance
students are at whether they're behind
in math even far behind the math they
can start with where they're confident
and strong and build on those strengths
you get more and more ready for PSAT for
s80 and really ready for college and
career readiness because that's the core
now what those exams measure yeah and
what I want to stress for everyone is a
lot of what we've been focused on our
team here at Khan Academy a software
engineers designers scientists have been
working on a personalization platform
where students go they can take some
practice tests some practice questions
and then based on that the software is
trying to say well what's the next best
thing that it should work on to get more
practice so that they can kind of
advance in the best possible ways
there's really you know no reason why
someone should feel intimidated it's all
stuff that they've seen in school and
they're gonna be able to get as much
practice as they need so go for it and
do your best all righty